this is the aftermath of the attack on
kuje correctional center on the
outskirts of abuja
gunmen entered the facility through the
back wall of the compound
firing sporadically and detonating
explosives
about 600 inmates escaped including
dozens of suspected boko haram fighters
more than 300 have been recaptured
or returned voluntarily
the police say the search is on to track
down all skps
authorities believe boko haram is behind
the jailbreak
they came
specifically for
their
co-conspirators and
but in order to get them some of them
are in general population so they broke
out and other people in that general
population escaped as well
the center holds nearly a thousand
prisoners
after a head count
dozens of suspected members of the armed
group were declared missing
the people who came to do these
activities
from the records
we believe that they belong to a
particular group
and most likely they are around
because we have sizable number of boko
harams
that are in detention
and
presently we could not locate any of
them
security has been beefed up at the
prison
but for families in kuja
the fear remains
the
experience of last night
was so bad and was so you know scary i
was far asleep
when i had a you know sound of gunshots
and a bomb blast
before i could know what was
happening someone just called me that i
should be
i should make sure that i'm a lot
that
there's a freezing
prison break
the attack adds to mounting insecurity
in the west african country
which is battling armed groups in the
north and sectarian violence in the
south
fidelis
al jazeera abuja